hey guys this is a bonus Christmas video
it was suggested to me on Twitter that I
should talk about my favorite books and
what I'm reading at the moment so I
thought that as well I'm not at union or
not doing PhD stuff it'd be nice thing
to do for Christmas so let's do that so
I'm the kind of person that likes to
have a few books on the go at any given
time there's one main book and then
history other books I'll dip in and out
of or a series that I'm dipping in and
out of the main book that I'm reading at
the moment is burn of Cornwall's
Waterloo I've only just started this I'm
on page 20 I think but it's a book
that's been sat on my bedside table for
a long time I know that he's a very good
author he wrote sharp for example like
too early to say if it's any good or not
so I can't really recommend it the book
that I just finished and the series I'm
taking a break from is Game of Thrones
I just finished a feast for crows this
one didn't take me for heard on a tour
despite the fact that they're each about
800 pages long and they never take me
that long to read because he just yeah I
get to a point like 200 pages out from
the end of my oh my god I've got to know
I just got to know I got to keep going
so you end up staying off until I 3 in
the morning reading I am a big fan of
Stannis Dumanis equally I actually stand
by the Hound I think it's a very complex
character and there's a whole bunch of
different hypotheses about I don't run
it people have read the books but for
example the gravedigger hypothesis I
equally love cleganebowl to be a thing
yeah I'm going to be reading after I
finish reading Waterloo I'm going to be
reading dance dragons the last fiction
book that I reading at the moment is
consider Philebus which is the first
book by in M banks obviously in banks
died quite recently and that that was
actually what take this off of my head I
know that he's going to be a very good
science fiction author and I thought
that it'd be worth giving it go also it
smells amazing it's got that new book
smell and that is as far as I can sell
the Western Isles in wealth and then
lastly the last thing which I'm reading
and dipping in and out of and I'm
hopefully going to read when I'm away in
America is this with five seasoned
cinematography which is basically a
cinema textbook I've always loved films
and recently I've been making an effort
to try and educate myself about making
them more in a more technical manner so
learning about cinematography learn
about editing watching essays going
through courses on it
because it is something that I've talked
about doing after graduating I would
love to go into filmmaking video making
full time and I thought that this would
be a good place to start and it is I'm
this book has been excellent I'm about
halfway through and it's really really
good stuff this now we come to the more
typical topic of my favorite books I
have before been quoted as saying that
Daryl Daryl is my family other animals
this is the the coffee that was given
when I was a kid is my favorite book and
I think if I had to pick one it would be
a good place to start because it's just
phenomenally enjoyable it's it's for
what it is which is a memoir effectively
and a call to arms for conservation it
is perfect you know it's great funny
it's warm it makes me incredibly jealous
of his childhood I absolutely love it if
you haven't read it do give dodo Laurie
because yeah I love it
once you get past that though things
start to get a bit more murky another
book which is on my bookshelf here which
had a huge huge impact on me was zen and
the art of motorcycle maintenance sorry
I really shiny and it was given to me
when I was I think about seventeen and
it really changed my philosophy
basically this is where my personal
philosophy comes from this book and I I
would sum it up but I don't think you
can I think to do so would would you
lose the message it's an odd one it's a
difficult read especially when you're 17
but I enjoyed it hugely it's made a
massive impact on me so suddenly
motorcycle maintenance bye bye Robert
and Pesek the other boat which I don't
have to hand at the moment which I made
the biggest impact on me was brave new
world by Aldous Huxley up here uh-huh
and that was the first book that really
taught me that just because something is
illogical doesn't mean something's right
especially as a kid you come from a
relatively non-emotional family
everything was very logical and that was
a wake-up call for me that logic wasn't
always the answer that's you know there
was humanity to be there to be
considered and it's a short little book
and it's horrifying but it's it's
gripping at the same time I read it too
young I read it when I was about 10 and
then I reread it when I was about 18 19
and I realized how much of an impact it
had on me but if you like 1984
I think brave new world is better
because it's about a dystopian where
people are bound by pleasure rather than
bound by fear which I think it's much
more realistic now we come to the part
of video where I'm just gonna rattle off
books that I really enjoyed and talk
about the briefly so go the Fault in Our
Stars basically required reading if
you're on YouTube plus my copy is in
fact sign like basically every human on
the planet I found it usually by deeply
emotionally moving even made my mom cry
and nothing makes my mom cry
His Dark Materials my copy is also
signed but I don't have it with me when
I was a kid the two big things were
Harry Potter and His Dark Materials and
while I do love Harry Potter because it
was like the first big series I
connected with I always preferred his
Dark Materials
I think the writing is amazing the
imagination is just it's it's phenomenal
like that the well building is amazing
and it's incredibly complex you know
morally complex it asks big questions
and if you haven't read it then yeah do
I'm gonna say that for every book so I
may as well just that that's implicit
from this point a science fiction double
feature
Gords ghosts this being represented by
the saint the middle part of the series
and the Horus heresy series represented
by Horus rising both by Dan Abnett this
is this is me nailing my key killers
families in masks but I'm a colossal
geek and these are Warhammer 40,000
books I really don't like it when people
put down fiction based on established
universes just because they're based in
the universe
it doesn't lessen the books themselves
they are hugely hugely entertaining they
are pulpy you know they these these
books are fast action a lot of killing
happens because it is military sci-fi
and again quite deep moral questions
that go on dan Abner is a really good
author who just happens to write books
10 to 14 of us in the same way that
other authors cover you good authors
that just write books set in the real
universe basically if you'd like sci-fi
action then I can Gods ghost is just the
best
also the eisenhorn series brothers of
the snake as well [ __ ] off so many fell
on sci-fi but really the kind of science
fact actually rather than the science
fiction the Martian by Andy weir if you
are an engineer or scientist or
mathematician or anything that involved
with logic and maths then you will love
this book it's like the best way that is
described as the xkcd comic that talks
about it being like that scene from
Apollo 13 when they make a square
go into a round hole but for 357 pages
it's amazing now for something
completely different Paradise Lost by
John Milton I sent myself the challenge
of reading this for those of you who
don't know this is an epic poem that was
written when was it written written in
1667 so it's Old English not
Shakespearean English but Old English
verse the way I describe it to my
friends is it's like literary
dark-chocolate you don't want much you
want a little bit at a time and when you
do have a little bit at a time it's
really really good yeah savor it not one
for everyone if you feel if you feel
like Bishop then give it a go and that's
a more rapid fire ones which are kind of
honorable mentions I guess but there's
no ranking really so yeah long way
around
excellent travel book brief history of
Medicine gotough my GCSE in history and
an absolutely loved it five and six Easy
Pieces given to me Oxford after the
summer school that went to in 2008 came
with me when I went travelling and went
up the Pyrenees and which is words a bit
raggedy and it's a great introduction if
you're thinking of doing a physics
degree read this book first medieval
views of the cosmos unusual one given to
be my parents from the body lune
basically it compares medieval in
Islamic attitudes towards mapping
towards astronomy and how very very
different they were in particularly the
mapping side of things I'm quite a fan
of maps the visual display of
quantitative information in my opinion
the book every scientist should read
unusual in that it's a textbook I
actually just read a pleasure really
good a brief history of nearly
everything by Bill Bryson amazing book
again if you're thinking of doing a
science degree at uni then go and read
this first because ah I loved it
I like sis adventures in numberland by
Alex bellos the book that got me into
math which is convenient because you
know it was just before I started doing
my maths PhD the strangest man which is
the biography of Paul Dirac who was a
Bristow lien physicist and undoubtedly
one of the strangest scientists in
history also definitely the best
scientific biography actually the best
biography I've ever read if you're into
bug fleas or into science give this book
a read really really interesting and
that's it my camera battery's about to
die so apparently that's that's a good
place to stop talking about books I
could go on forever and ever but please
leave in the comments if you have
opinions like very strong opinions
possibly if you disagree with some of my
choices leave them down in the comments
and also be interested to hear what are
your favorite books because I'm always
looking out for more stuff to read and
there are only two more Game of Thrones
books left so I need
Foundation's thanks very much for
watching I hope having a great Christmas
and I look forward to talking to you all
in the comments
quantum by magic kima this is a book
about the historical development of
quantum mechanics and it is possibly the
best popular science account out on the
road having now started singing because
I didn't sing before I came to Exeter
and I in the past two years have been
made aware of its like whole new world
of music that's really really good
there's read about Christmas so what
I've done is I have made a playlist